>> TO HAVE A WORD, IT SORT OF
BECAME OLD-FASHIONED.
IT'S CALLED A NATIONALIST.
I SAID REALLY, WE'RE NOT
SUPPOSED TO USE THAT WORD?
THE KNOW WHAT I AM?
I'M A NATIONALIST.
>> Laura: PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
DEFENDED HIS USE OF THE TERM
NATIONALISM AS AN INTENSE LOVE
OF ONE'S COUNTRY.
BUT LEFTIST COMMENTATORS AND
OTHER INTERNATIONAL LISTS SAY A
DOG WHISTLE.
A WHITE SUPREMACIST.
AND ON AN OCCASION COMMEMORATING
THE 100 YEAR -- FRENCH
PRESIDENT EMMANUEL MIKE
MACRON HAS JOINED THE FRAY.
>> NATIONALISM IS A BETRAYAL OF
PATRIOTISM BY SAYING OURS FIRST,
WHO CARES ABOUT THE OTHERS?
>> Laura: JOINING ME NOW, THE
AUTHOR OF THE BOOK "THE VIRTUE
OF NATIONALISM," AND FORMER NATO
CHIEF OF STAFF.
LET ME START WITH YOU.
WHAT DID MACRON GET WRONG HERE
ABOUT NATIONALISM?
>> WELL, LAURA, MACRON IS
PURSUING THE SAME AGENDA THAT
HE'S REPEATED.
AT THE UNITED NATIONS, MACRON
TOLD US HE DEPLORES A WORLD THAT
HE CALLS A WORLD OF LAWLESSNESS
IN WHICH EVERYBODY PURSUES THEIR
OWN INTEREST.
MACRON HAS THE IDEA OF THE
PROBLEM WITH NATIONAL INTEREST.
HE SAYS THAT NATIONAL INTEREST
IS NATIONAL SELFISHNESS.
HE'S TELLING PRESIDENT TRUMP TO
BE A NATIONALIST AND PURSUE YOUR
OWN INTEREST IS A BETRAYAL OF
MORAL VALUES.
>> Laura: ALL RIGHT, THIS IS
WHAT CHRISTIAN WHITTEN IS SAYING
ABOUT MACRON'S COMMENTARY.
LET'S WATCH.
>> I THINK MACRON WITHIN THE
E.U. IS UNDER A LOT OF PRESSURE.
FRANKLY GERMANY IS WILLING TO
CUT A DEAL ON THE TRADE CHANGES
THAT TRUMP WANTS, TO LOWER
TARIFFS ACROSS THE BOARD.
MACRON DOESN'T LIKE THAT.
HE DOESN'T LIKE HAVING TO SPEND
MORE ON THE MILITARY.
HE DOESN'T LIKE THE FACT THAT
ITALY, ALONG WITH BRITAIN,
PEELING AWAY FROM THE E.U.
NOT QUITE AS DIRECTLY.
EASTERN EUROPE NOT AS KOSHER ON
THE E.U.
A LOT OF THESE THINGS AREN'T
GOING THE WAY THIS FORM THIS
FORMER INVESTMENT BANKER WOULD
LIKE THEM TO GO.
>> Laura: IF GLOBALISM OF THE
SORT THAT MACRON LOVES, AND
INTERNATIONALISM, WAS HELPING
THE AVERAGE GERMAN OR FRENCHMAN,
THERE WOULDN'T BE A BACKLASH
AGAINST INTERNATIONALISM OR
GLOBALISM.
THERE WOULD BE LET'S DO MORE OF
IT.
BUT THEY ARE UNDER ENORMOUS
PRESSURE, ARE THEY NOT?
>> THEY ABSOLUTELY ARE.
THIS SPEECH, THERE IS TO GO
PARTS OF THE SPEECH.
ONE IS MACRON IS A CAPITAL
ENCAPSULATING
HIMSELF AS AN OPPONENT OF
TRUMP --
>> Laura: AS A NATIONAL FRONT
PUSHING BACK ON HIM.
THEY'VE HAD GAINS IN RECENT
POLLS.
>> THIS IS RISKY FOR MACRON
BECAUSE HE IS EUROPEAN ELECTIONS
WHICH WILL BE A BAROMETER FOR
HIS OWN TERM.
HE'S ISOLATED BECAUSE MRS.
MRS. MERKEL, HER POLITICAL
AMBITIONS ARE ON THE DECLINE.
THIS IS A WARNING THAT
NATIONALISM AND POPULISM THAT
FUELED WORLD WAR I IS ON THE
RISE AND IT'S A DANGER TO THE
EUROPEAN CONTINENT, I THINK HE
WAS BRAVE ON MAKING THAT
STATEMENT ON THE SPEECH.
>> Laura: THIS IS WHAT THEY
SAID TODAY ABOUT WHAT
NATIONALISM ACTUALLY CREATES.
LET'S WATCH.
>> WHAT LED TO WORLD WAR I AND
WERE GOING TO IS NATIONALISM,
BASICALLY.
IT'S DIVISIONS AND EUROPEAN
ALLIES SAW THE CONSEQUENCES OF
THEIR DESTROYED COUNTRY.
WHEN MACRON SAYS COLLABORATION
AND FIGHTING TOGETHER FOR THE
COMMON GOOD, TALKS ABOUT
CREATING A EUROPEAN ARMY, YOU
HAVE TO WATCH FOR THESE THINGS
AND I FEEL LIKE THIS IS THE
BEGINNING OF THE EUROPEAN
SATURATION
SEPARATION FROM AMERICA.
THIS IS REALLY SCARY.
>> Laura: THIS IS REALLY
SCARY.
WHY IS IT SCARY FOR EUROPE TO
SPEND MORE MONEY ON EUROPE'S
DEFENSE?
100 YEARS AFTER WORLD WAR I
ARMISTICE?
WHY IS THAT CALAMITOUS TO THE
INTERNATIONALISTS?
I'M NOT FOLLOWING THAT.
>> THIS IS THE SAME PROPAGANDA
WE'VE BEEN HEARING FROM LIBERAL
INTELLECTUALS IN EUROPE SENDS
RIGHT AFTER WORLD WAR II.
THEY ALWAYS HAVE THE SAME MANTRA
THAT NATIONALISM CAUSED THE
WORLD WARS.
HISTORICALLY, IF YOU GO AFTER
WORLD WAR I YOU'LL SEE THAT MOST
PEOPLE AFTER WORLD WAR I
BELIEVED THAT WHAT CAUSED THE
FIRST WORLD WAR TO GO ON FOR
FOUR AND A HALF YEARS AND TO
LEAP TO 20 MILLION DEATHS WAS
THE LIFE AND DEATH STRUGGLE
BETWEEN GERMAN IMPERIALISM
TRYING TO BREAK THE BACK OF
BRITISH IMPERIALISM AND ITS
EFFORT TO TAKE OVER THE WORLD.
WITH WORLD WAR II, YOU CAN SAY
THE SAME THING.
ADOLF HITLER, IF HE HADN'T
WANTED TO TAKE OVER THE WORLD,
IF HE HADN'T SAID IN "MEIN
KAMPF" WAS TO MAKE GERMANY AND
THE LORD OF THE EARTH AND
MISTRESS IN GLOBE, MIGHT'VE BEEN
A TERRIBLE GERMAN LEADER BUT
WOULD NOT HAVE LED TO THE DEATHS
OF 50-60000000 PEOPLE.
>> Laura: JUST VERY QUICKLY
RESPOND TO THAT.
NATION-BUILDING, WANTING TO
TRANSPOSE OUR VIEW OF DEMOCRACY
ON OTHER NATIONS, WE'VE LOST
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS, COUNTLESS
LIVES, DAMAGE LIVES AT HOME,
DEPLETED OUR MILITARY, WE
WEREN'T PURSUING NATIONALIST
AGENDA IN IRAQ OR AFGHANISTAN OR
THROUGHOUT THE MIDDLE EAST, WENT
WITH?
>> NO, BUT WHAT I THINK MACRON
IS SAYING IS THAT EUROPE HAS
MAINTAINED PEACE WHEN THE
TRANSLATED COMMUNITY HAS
COOPERATED.
WHEN THE COMMON ELEMENTS OF
COMMON SECURITY, WHICH NATO
REPRESENTS, ACTUALLY SUPPORTS
AMERICAN INTEREST AND SUPPORT
FRENCH, GERMAN, U.K. INTERESTS.
THERE IS A RISK TODAY THAT
TRANSATLANTIC UNITY IS FALLING
APART.
>> Laura: WHERE ARE THEY GOING
TO GO, INTO THE ARMS OF CHINA?
>> NO.
I THINK THE FEAR IS TRUMP IS
GOING TO TAKE THE UNITED STATES
OUT OF THE GAME AND RUSSIA AND
CHINA CAN CREATE CONFLICT LIKE